Yeah, happy to be back and uh welcome to
wipe hacking. Now, in the next 20
minutes, I will share some of the threat
research we've seen um around AI
assisted threats and also share mentor
model with you. All right. And um I
think all the speakers yesterday and
today, they really showed us how AI is
accelerating offense. We've got faster
exploits, we've got faster recon, we've
got faster everything, and they're all
right. But um on the other hand, the
same the same speed which GI is
providing to offense is also creating
the most noisy attacks we've ever seen.
And
the fastest the go, the more they
confess. So let this sing in with you.
The faster they go, the more they
confess.
Now, 28th of November last year, we've
caught a intrusion into AWS environment.
A very classic one. S3 bucket
credentials were compromised out of a
rack database. And within 8 minutes,
those guys got a full admin. And we've
caught everything. All the cloud trail
locks, all the SUS um uh Cisco logs. And
they were not just fast. They were
pretty pretty loud. So let me let me
show you.
First of all, you see this type of
comments like courageous admin access
key list S3 bucket. Does somebody
understand this? It's Sherbin.
And this is a lambda function which uh
the attackers tried to execute three
times literally within a minute. It was
pretty well done. You see multiple user
accounts uh exception handling and so
on. They've succeeded the third time.
Now next they've tried to assume some
rows and move lateral ascending and
descending numbers. Now this are not
going to work obviously in the
environment of um of AWS. Um do you
recognize a pattern there? If you ask
your favorite AI
generate example EWS account ids for me.
This is what you get. This is what they
learn through the training process. And
you will find much more other
information if you just ask for some
training or sample data.
Now next guess what kind of AI they were
using. It's a bit obvious from this raw
session name. They were confessing
without even knowing that they were
confessing this specific breach. And our
code is obviously very powerful for good
thing but also for bad things as we've
seen um yesterday and today. So that was
very obvious to us. But next next step
what was a even more obvious because
what they've tried to do is uh they've
tried to spin up some GPU um GPUs um
8100 you know eight of them um you would
pay what like 50 hours um an hour for
them um and they had some problems but
first of all they named the GPUs Steven
GPU monster Steven is a ser and this
name popped up as well multiple times in
the locks which is very interesting. So
if you know a Steven out of Serbia who's
doing a lot with CL let me know perhaps
u we can help them with with OBSAC. Now
they've tried then the LM didn't really
the attacker didn't really succeeded. So
um the LM tried really to find some
training scripts to understand what was
really happening. Obviously this GitHub
repo doesn't exist. I don't know if it's
if it's one I don't know why why they
were trying to do this but it was simply
not there. So it was as well again
coming from hallucination. Now what's
exciting is you've seen within 8 minutes
them going to full admin and then there
was a full stop for about 50 minutes no
activity
a burst of activity no activity and then
another burst of activity and this is
like typical prompting behaviors were
right you prompt the LM is doing
something uh very successfully and then
you're waiting for its master but
actually had multiple of such attacks
running in parallel
now let me introduce you to another guy.
Do you remember this meme blockchain
enabled AI hacker which were was like
viral about 5 years ago? This guy became
real last year. And um we've literally
seen this attack just popping up um a
couple of days after the first attacker
24 hours after React for shell
exploitation. If you remember react for
shell, it was exploited literally after
a couple of hours when it went live. Uh
we floed um we floed this sample and um
it would come with five persistence
mechanisms. It would come with a you
know local runtime um environment no
jets. It would be able to patch itself
on the fly. It would deliver multiple
payloads literally within a couple of
minutes. So we have we don't have the
smoking gun to say that they were
generated with the eye. the the way how
the code is written the way um how the
comments were done is definitely
suggesting this. So I'm not sure if we
have some good uh researchers from
OpenDI on trophic and we have some
watermarking techniques if if you guys
are doing this you can prove that happy
to share this uh this fast with you but
I think the the amount of um code as
well being produced within this amount
of uh time just suggesting as well it
was an LLM. Now, next, they made this
campaign unkillable because they've put
the C2 server on a blockchain.
It was literally live on a blockchain
and you can't really size it, right? You
can't really block it. You can't take it
down because there's no registar you can
go to and just try to to sync all of
that. Um so at this point in time you as
a researcher you might be worried but
don't because
looking at all the different ways how an
AI is trying to act first of all speed
we've seen the speed is creating a lot
of different artifacts
which are persisting which are
confessing in your locks you just need
to find them resilience most likely
they've asked as well for resilient way
to have a good C2 infrastructure create
a lot of forensic evidence is going to
live forever now the blockchain and you
can literally see all the different C2s
all the different activities as well
from this specific campaign but also
scale because the way how quickly all
the different payloads were produced and
how they were used is also suggesting we
can identify this now what are you doing
if you're facing the ice threat you try
to wipe back right let's create a
dedicated custom um mount where sync
assessment environment was practically
not a synchole and um you know just
track the thread actor in real time and
that's uh what we've done unfortunately
oh the video is loading great so you
know what it would do it would just pull
out all the different um uh RPC calls
all different C2s uh try to understand
the content content what is um what is
the uh the leading C2 uh try then to
load u the payloads um the opuscate ing
understand what it's doing have its
versioning system as well do a trend
analysis how the malware is changing as
well so the days where we do malware
analysis is changing can be very easy as
well if you just fight back with uh with
wipe coding
now still I guess just looking as well
the zero day clock I've presented before
the speed of of the attackers and the
the shift more towards offense is going
to stay around um
And you know the reason for that is
explained here on the slide. Offense has
very cheap verifiers.
If you pop a shell, if you run a binary,
it's a very deterministic clear
verifier.
Defense has a sim suspicious information
every minute. Are you familiar with
this?
See everybody, right? So it's not very
very easy to verify in a deterministic
way something happened. Now what offense
doesn't have they don't have really this
way to understand your environment
to call the right GitHub repo to create
the right account which is following
your name it convention to understand
how your environment is being set up and
this is what we can as defenders we have
this this way to verify if data is real
or not because we understand our
environment much more better now last
year I've presented this this mentor
model which was derived from um um from
Jason Wei from OpenAI who sort of
abstractly described the way AI is
becoming really good and you know one
one example to think about this is if
you have this spectrum of solutions and
a spectrum of verification you can map
Sudoko for instance in it sudokco is
very very easy to verify right but very
hard to generate there's tons of
solutions millions of solutions out
there diet is a counter example for that
because if I eat today something I will
see the results in a couple weeks or
months that's where AI is not really
good so now what I've tried to do is
I've tried to map cyber security domains
to this space and just looking at most
of the offensive capabilities
you see that they are very often much
more easier to verify than the defense
capabilities because it's very easy
again if you have an exploit you can it
out dynamically if you have a shell
you're popping if you're exfating data.
So it's much more dynamic. It's much
more dynamic and deterministic in this
way uh compared to defense because for
defense now looking at a binary
looking at your SIM information looking
at your code repo it's not that easy to
verify if if it's malicious or not. Like
the perfect example for this is is a
malware.
As MA analysts, we've tried always to
make verification very cheap by um you
know analyzing the specific binary,
finding bad patterns and generating out
of those bad patterns a hash or finding
or trying to build a stage in between by
having sandboxes in place right and you
can take this analogy as well to many
other domains who have tried to make
this verification being very very cheap.
Now going back to what I was saying
before,
what we see right now is offense is
owning the objective verifiers.
If you want to do something, this is
where offense is really, really good.
But we as defense, we have this unique
advantage to own the environment
verifiers
because once an attacker is in our
environment, they don't understand what
to do. They understand how our
environment is being set up. Now let me
share with you some practical um
examples how this might look like
because um
you know perhaps I ask first of all a
question how many of you are here not
not Americans a quick hands of show okay
me too I'm German so if you um if you
try to speak very slow as German some
people might not hear that you're not
American I mean now I'm having a cold
and It's pretty obvious. I'm pretty bad
at this. But now if you speak very fast,
you get an accent. You have a very clear
way to identify that somebody is a
forrunner, right? Because you speak fast
and all the things you've learned from
your language are coming up. So if you
want to have a good mental model, the AI
which is being trained, it's having an
accent based on the training data it's
it's learned and it will always try to
follow its accent if it has to go fast.
Obviously we can go back and ask the
first of all to enumerate the
environment to enormerate all the
different things u before doing some
dangerous actions but then you give up
the speed and then you also have all
these different other controls we've
built around. So four controls um you
can think of is um you know reflected
here. So first one is weaponize time in
the attack in the first attack we've
seen literally within 5 minutes you
would see specific account being created
from an unknown source and then
performing admin activities that's a bad
one right it's pretty clear that if
something like that is happening and you
have this timing based control something
is new something is fresh like we've
been doing with DNS as well new domain
names being created you can analyze them
all the time that's pretty bad set an
alert based on this setting traps honey
tokens the best the only best thing in
cyber defense you can find on there. If
you don't have honey tokens today in
your environment, you're potentially not
going to attack good uh good attackers.
So set up canaries identities which are
following the naming convention of the
identities in your environment of your
company. Third, um, enforce your accent.
And what I mean by this is make sure
that your team understands all the
different naming convention, all the
different GitHub repos, everything you
your company has built and learned to
operate and set up certain rules and
detections around that. But first of
all, train your team so that they
understand that they can distinguish
that a certain alert doesn't follow this
naming convention. And then the last one
is um and that's where it's it's a very
cheap verifier. You can always verify if
certain things are real or not real. If
somebody is calling an account name,
right? If somebody is trying to assume
roles, if somebody's trying to call a
GitHub repo, you can just build alerts
or at least monitoring observation rules
based on that. Now what's important to
understand this is something which
where you will not find a vendor who can
help you solve that because it's you
customtailored environment. That's
something you have to do and you don't
need special technology for this you
know cloud detection response tool sim
tools this is where you can replicate
this type of rules
now and with this um I think I want to
want to summarize that the attackers
don't know all this internal knowledge
of our environment of our company we've
built over time they don't know the
repos you have they don't know how you
deploy they don't know how you um you
know name your reports not identities
whatever this is where we can accumulate
knowledge and the attacker CI has
definite accent
and speed makes it louder so let's start
listening thank you very much
thank you all right we'll start
questions over
Great chat. Um, I noticed the one thing
that was below the line that you know
favors defense as honey tokens which
feels like it's always the thing that
security teams like we should be doing
more with honey tokens and then they
don't and it does feel like you know how
given how noisy and you know the accent
that AI has it is a potentially tool
that security teams should be leveraging
more often. Curious if you agree if your
team at Cyc is using them just how you
think about that. Sorry, can you repeat
the last sentence?
>> Oh, just um if your team at Cydig is
using honey tokens in a big way, if you
agree that becomes a more important uh
tool in the defender's arsenal in this
era.
>> Oh, yes. I mean, I think it's not a
secret that the most successful vendors
out there all using honey tokens. Um
like even EDR solutions, that's the way
how you detect as well enumerations and
things like that. So and right now
specifically with the i said speed is
becoming very loud and if somebody wants
to be silent then they would need to
start enumerating things across the
environment. So honey tokens across the
environment are becoming pretty key.
There are some other techniques as well
but honey tokens are the most
deterministic way uh for defenders um to
to deal about the problem with the
problem.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah great talk. Thanks for the analogy
of the accent. Um my question is around
how many accents have you captured of
the attackers?
>> So I think that's a great research
topic. A couple of good great research
topics you might want to explore. Just
building now environments where you can
have multiple models driving the same
type of attack and then trying to
understand what the models are going to
perform right that could be one. And
then there's there's a tons of um
questions as well around the cyber
security verifiers law. So everything I
mapped right now on this um you know on
this graph has to be proven
mathematically as well um right in in
proper studies. So there's a lot of open
question but the the evidence we've seen
from last research everything we've been
discussing yesterday and today is
suggesting that offense is just
accelerating much more faster and has
this better way as well to in both in
training but also in inference to be
more successful.
>> Any other questions audience?
All right. Thank you so much.
>> Thank you.